My name is um sorry.
My question is about John chapter 5
verse 13.
Uh
the and and also John 4 John's 14 verse
28. It said
John
uh it said Jesus said
I'm not doing it it's my will I do will
of my father.
So
my question is do you agree with that
thing Jesus speak?
I heard your question somewhat.
If you are if I'm not mistaken you are
asking Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said I'm the way the truth and the life
no man comes unto the father but through
me. Is this what you're referring to?
So
That's my mic.
Yes, that's my question.
quote correctly. I could hear part but
the quotation was not exact.
So you are telling me that this is
mentioned in the Bible correct?
Yeah.
So what does it mean?
So do you agree Jesus says my father do
you agree with the same that Jesus in
the the Quran Jesus it's same Jesus do
you believe?
100% agree with what he's saying but
what do you mean when he says this?
Whatever you mean my question is
Do you agree?
Uh yes I'm agree.
100% Okay now I understand your question
but I believe you're not well versed
with the Bible.
Because the quotation was half it wasn't
correct. I will give you what you're
talking is you're quoting a reference
from the Bible Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number six.
No no no. Gospel of John chapter 14
verse 28 and the just just all of John
chapter 5 verse 13. Do you agree about
by those chapters?
What does it say?
It says my father keep saying Jesus my
father. Do you agree the Quran
Jesus and the the Bible?
Yeah.
Gospel of John?
Chapter 5 verse 30.
Gospel of John, chapter 5, verse 30.
Verse 30, 30, 3 0.
That I know by heart.
Mhm?
Gospel of John, chapter 5, verse number
30, I know.
Yes.
It says, "I can of my own self do
nothing. As I hear, I judge, for
judgment is just, for I seek not my
will, BUT THE WILL OF MY FATHER."
SO, do you agree?
I agree with it. But, what you quoted
earlier was different. NOW, YOU'RE
QUOTING 5:30. WHY ARE you changing?
5:30 is in my memory.
Yes, I know.
I
I HAVE TO AGREE. Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him, said in Gospel of John,
chapter number 5, verse number 30, "I
can of my own self do nothing.
As I hear, I judge, and my judgment is
just, FOR I SEEK NOT MY WILL, BUT THE
WILL OF MY FATHER." And whenever Jesus
Christ, peace be upon him, used in the
Bible, "my father", it means he's
referring to God.
So, what did Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, say in Gospel of John, chapter 5,
verse number 30? "I can of my own self
do nothing." Jesus Christ on his OWN CAN
DO ZERO.
OKAY.
WAIT, WAIT, let me complete.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Wait, you asked the question, listen to
the answer. Your question is over.
You have not come here to debate,
correct?
In the question answer session, you ask
a question,
and you listen to the answer. Do you
understand English?
Yeah, yeah.
"I can of my own self do nothing." Jesus
Christ said, "On his own, HE CAN DO
NOTHING, ZERO. AS I HEAR, I JUDGE, AND
MY JUDGMENT IS JUST, FOR I SEEK NOT MY
WILL, BUT THE WILL OF MY FATHER. Seek
not my will, BUT WILL OF almighty God.
Anyone who says, "I seek not my will,
but the will of almighty God", is a
Muslim. So, according to me, when I read
the Bible, Jesus Christ said, "I CANNOT
DO ANYTHING.
AS I HEAR, I JUDGE,
AND MY JUDGMENT IS JUST, FOR I SEEK NOT
MY WILL, BUT THE WILL OF MY GOD."
SO, THAT MEANS YOU ARE THE MUSLIM. YOU
ARE THE MESSENGER OF GOD. SO, I 100%
believe
Sir. with this verse OF THE BIBLE,
CHAPTER 5 VERSE NUMBER 30. Do you
believe?
Yes, 100% I believe. So, if you believe
Jesus Jesus has a father in in Quran
whole whole Quran
uh God you are claiming in Christianity
God father's is God, right?
So, in whole Quran
there is no mention the father. You are
not called Allah my father, right?
Of course we don't.
So,
in basis Jesus not miss Muslim. Someone
when you say I am
analyze my father Allah
he is out of
Islamity, right?
Correct.
So, how you say Jesus you say keep says
my father my father, but you say you
reject.
Jesus Christ peace be upon him came
before Prophet
Listen.
Now you ask
Sorry, sorry, sorry. This in front of me
for respect. Don't say Jesus peace upon
him.
Brother brother wait.
If you want to debate you can hire the
hall. If you want to debate
I'm not drinker.
Yeah, I'm not drinker. I'm normal man.
the question answer time. Do you
understand English in question answer
time? You ask your question and you keep
quiet.
Yeah, I'm good guy.
Ask your question and you keep quiet. Do
you understand?
Yeah, answer for me.
When your priest preach they don't allow
YOU TO ASK QUESTION ALSO.
I'm I'm ask you professional question.
I'm giving the answer. Will you keep
quiet?
This is not debate. If you want to
debate CALL THE MOST FAMOUS
PRIEST IN AFRICA WHO CAN GET 30 40,000
I'll debate with him.
You understand? YOU ARE A KID. What do
you do debating with you?
You ask the question I'll give the
reply.
You told me anyone in Islam calls Allah
father is wrong. OF COURSE IT'S WRONG
Because father is not THE ATTRIBUTE OF
ALMIGHTY GOD.
CORRECT? BUT ANY THIS IS AFTER THE QURAN
WAS REVEALED. JESUS WAS PRESENT BEFORE
THE QURAN WAS REVEALED.
SO, FOR JESUS CHRIST
WHEN MUHAMMAD DID NOT COME, PEACE BE
UPON HIM, he doesn't have to believe IN
MUHAMMAD. HE DIDN'T PROPHESY. DO YOU
UNDERSTAND? SO, all the laws of Quran
ARE ONLY APPLICABLE AFTER THE QURAN WAS
REVEALED. JESUS CHRIST came before the
Quran was revealed. Do you understand?
So, because Jesus Christ was the
messenger of Allah at his TIME
WHATEVER HE PREACHED WAS CORRECT.
BUT IF YOU GET A WRONG TEACHING, WE
DON'T AGREE with that. So, I'm saying
Jesus, peace be upon him. Jesus Christ,
peace be upon him said in the Bible,
THOUGH I DO NOT AGREE THE FULL BIBLE to
be the word of God, but this was Gospel
of John, CHAPTER NUMBER FIVE, VERSE
NUMBER 30. I CORRECT I agree it is 100%
correct.
So, you are out of Islamity if you if
you believe that Jesus is
Now, you have come to teach me Islam
here, correct? What do you know about
Islam?
What do you know about Islam?
And I'm the man more born in Islam. I
don't know.
If you if you do not believe in Jesus,
PEACE BE UPON HIM, THEN YOU'RE OUTSIDE
ISLAM.
NO.
NO. NO. NO. NO. JESUS, peace be upon
him, YOU'RE OUTSIDE ISLAM. ANYONE WHO
CAME before the Quran was revealed,
their laws are different.
ALL THE PROPHETS OF GOD BELIEVE IN ONE
GOD.
At that time, there was no rule that you
cannot call God father.
Is there any mention anywhere in the
Quran that you can't call God Allah
before Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon
him? Prophet Jesus, peace be upon him,
was a messenger of God.
He was a messenger of God. He's saying,
"I CAN OF MY OWN SELF DO NOTHING." THAT
MEANS HE'S ZERO.
SO, DO you you change your Allah change
his mind?
Allah doesn't change the mind.
So, why you saying?
Allah is not changing the mind. You are
saying this.
You said before this
for prophet of before
Allah's father, but no it's no father.
Will you Will you keep quiet? You are
breaking the rule. Do you understand?
You are breaking the rule. YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
YOU ARE YOU ARE BREAKING THE RULE IN
QUESTION AND THE TIME YOU ASK A QUESTION
AND YOU KEEP QUIET. YOU AREN'T ALLOWED
TO INTERJECT. THIS IS NOT A DEBATING
SESSION. DO YOU UNDERSTAND ENGLISH? I
think your English is poor. You have to
go back to school to learn English.
It's okay.
It's okay. It's okay. It's okay. If my
English is poor, but I understand you.
That's not fun of me, huh?
Everybody's not fun of me.
When you go to standard one,
then you go to standard two, then you go
to standard three, you keep on getting
more knowledge.
There is no contradiction.
If
If you are a kid and you are saying
something in a nursery different, the
moment you keep on studying higher, you
get more and more knowledge. As far as
Allah is concerned, Allah kept on
sending revelation.
The examination keeps on changing
depending upon the subject you have to
study.
So, at the time of Jesus, peace be upon
him, he was the messenger of almighty
God.
We believe that he believed in Allah and
he spread the message OF ALLAH AT THAT
TIME.
At that time when he said
called almighty God as father, NO
PROBLEM, BUT YOU ALL STARTED
MISUNDERSTANDING HIM. SO, WHEN YOU ALL
STARTED misunderstanding him, that that
is in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the
glorious Quran, he doesn't repeat
everything verbatim.
Whatever is IN THE PAST IS DIFFERENT.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Maidah,
chapter 5, verse number 3, "On this day
have I perfected your religion for you
and I have chosen for you Islam.
And have completed my favor on you.
After this nothing new can be added OR
SUBTRACTED.
I'M ASKING YOU THE QUESTION. WHEN THE
FATHER IS GOD THAT MEANS JESUS IS NOT
GOD. DO YOU BELIEVE JESUS IS GOD?
YES, HE'S ANOTHER PERSON.
THERE IS THERE IS NO CONTRADICTION.
There may be a contradiction.
Wait, wait, wait. Jesus said I can of my
own SELF DO NOTHING. THAT MEANS YOUR GOD
CAN DO NOTHING.
SO, do you
you.
Shame don't solve me. Respect. Shame on
you, too. Don't solve me.
So,
Here everybody is telling YOU YOUR GOD
CAN DO NOTHING.
YOUR GOD CANNOT DO ANYTHING.
YOU QUOTED THE VERSE OF THE OF the
Bible, Gospel of John CHAPTER NUMBER
FIVE, VERSE NUMBER 30. Jesus Christ
peace be upon HIM SAYS, "I CAN OF MY OWN
SELF DO NOTHING." GOD WILL NEVER SAY I
CANNOT DO.
SO, HE SAY I WILL I will do the will of
my father.
Wait.
Please Please respect the speaker. Let
him answer.
I respect him but he's He make me fun of
me. Why?
Hold your question.
Because
Because you are contradicting. You don't
understand English.
I understand.
Please Please turn off the microphone.
The brother is crazy. Please can you He
wants to preach.
He wants to preach.
The brother wants to preach. WHAT DO YOU
DO? You hire this tent.
You see?
You hire this tent.
man.
In your gathering the Christian
missionary never allow anyone TO ASK A
QUESTION. WE ARE GIVING YOU SO MUCH
TIME. YOU ARE WASTING EVERYONE'S TIME.
YOU ARE MAKING A FOOL OUT OF YOURSELF.
YOU ARE SAYING GOD CAN DO NOTHING.
HOW CAN I AGREE? I LOVE MY JESUS CHRIST
PEACE BE upon him. If you don't LOVE HIM
THAT'S YOUR PROBLEM.
SO, the brother is quoting from the
Bible Gospel of John chapter 5 verse
number 13. Jesus Christ peace be upon
him said, "I can of my own self do
nothing." So God ALMIGHTY IN NO RELIGION
will ever say, "I can of my own self do
nothing." So this proves that Jesus
peace be upon HIM WAS NOT GOD. IF YOU
CANNOT UNDERSTAND ENGLISH IT'S YOUR
PROBLEM NOT MY PROBLEM. AND YOU'RE
KEEPING ON repeating repeating repeating
repeating.
Can we have the next question?